I heard you talking Paul about that
actually when you got to set you were a
bit like that you were kind of
fangirling Ronnie yeah we shot ant-man
and but I was alone on that I was like
working in a in a bubble pretty much and
then all of a sudden I'm standing around
and seeing Robert Downey jr. and the
Iron Man suit and seeing Chris Evans and
they're all there I've seen the movies
and I felt like I was I was 10 years old
it was crazy
oh did you read you the touching the
arms but yeah yeah I saw I saw Sebastian
Stan getting his arm the silver arm on
and it was weird I was like I was
watching somebody bathing I'm not
supposed to see this but I did I went
over and I could contain a fell B arm
and Chris Evans had to run to the
bathroom really quick so so he asked the
prop guy he was can you just hold this
he was holding his shield he ran off
hunter than I imagined no it's made of
vibranium of course it's gonna be in
yeah course yes
no it was it was it was pretty cool I
must say
your own state secrets there you know
love us you told it drama school if you
don't lay off the church and never play
Juliet
so which one oh boy Julia I mean tasted
chips